elections have consequences we get the
gov what was it h.l mencken said that
democracy is the theory that the people
deserve
deserve to get what they want and they
deserve to get it good and hard so
kamala harris yesterday she summed it up
very well when she explained what
elections mean
as we all know elections matter
and when folks vote they order what they
want and in this case they got what they
asked for
i went off script a little bit
she is so
singularly unlikable
i have basically nothing else to add to
that clip other than that she's just
so
painfully unlikable
joe biden's approval rating is about
negative 15 right now and hers is lower
if if democrats really believe that
kamala harris is their great hope in
2024 i think they ought to pack it in
now and republicans should start
measuring the drapes
elections
have
and your order and i went off script i
know you did darling i know you went off
script a lot of the meat that you buy in
the supermarket is just crap and it's
mislabeled and they say it's product of
the usa and it's really imported from
some cheap ranch overseas and then the
cartels here just minimally process it
and they say product of usa don't get
that good ranchers goes to actual
american ranches gets really high
quality beef and chicken by the way they
got great steaks they got great
hamburgers they bring them to you the
prices cannot be beat the packaging is
perfect because they package it in
individual helpings so right something
like 40 of the meat in the united states
just gets thrown out doesn't end up
being eaten because you buy the big pack
of it and you only eat some of it and
the leftovers you can throw it out
you're not gonna have that problem with
good ranchers i love their stuff i'm
very excited today for mardi gras
the good ranchers have shown up and
they're throwing a big barbecue for us
and i get to eat their delicious new
york strip steak and it's gonna be a
blast right now you can get a 30
discount on prime steaks and better than
organic chicken today you go to
goodranchers.com
knowles
to save on the quality that you have
been looking for that is
goodranchers.com
knowles they take the guesswork out of
the grocery store they source everything
from local farms they ship it to your
door use the code knolls get a box of
100 american meat 30 in savings combat
inflation
get your delicious meat delivered go to
good ranchers right now i'm so glad you
liked that clip now you got to ring the
bell
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications especially this is what
you really got to do head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts do it right now i'll wait
you got it out good
uh type in the michael and i'll show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you